[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلنا الاولين الله يرحمهم
كانوا اذا كسروا
ولا وجدوا فيه ماء وذاقه وهدب الاثل وجدوا
ولا حموضه خفيفه قالوا ترى مربعانيه
الشتاء دخلت واذا افرزه الصدره والطلحه
ماده حمراء او صفراء
قالوا ترى مربعانيه البيض دخلت والعرب
القدماء يقولون اذا حاضت السدره فهذا
اماره على شده الحر ففي مربعانيه الشتاء
يتوقف الماء عن الجريان في غصون الاشجار
فتقص استخدام للعصي او البناء او الاواني
المنزليه وقمه البؤشي ان تبكيك ذاكره
بمنزل كنت دوما فيه
تبتسم
والعرب القدماء لهم طرق شتى في معرفه
الفصول والواسم مختلفه باختلاف الثقافات
والبيئه المحيطه بهم فالزراع على السلوك
الزراعي والباديه على السلوك الحشري وعلى
تحركات الرياح وتخلقات السحب واهل البحر
على الرؤيه العيانيه لذات النجم ومشارق
الشمس وقالوا تتوب على الهواء قلت لا لا
تتوب الشمس
فرق
[موسيقى]